how important is the beginning when you
first hit the stage
he's pretty huge when you start because
if you don't have the right footing with
the crowd you're lost but when you get
to be a veteran it doesn't matter
it really doesn't matter I mean you you
walk out there and if you don't get them
right there and you'll get applause
because they know you and you're a big
king of comedy but you know that even if
for whatever reason you can get them
yeah it doesn't matter and as a matter
of fact you can loot throw them back and
get them back again that's that's where
you get really great that's where you
can get really good because he can just
go you guys go away you can piss him off
and then you go yeah I know you seem
like you're upset because when you're on
stage you tell you know the future you
control the future they don't know what
you're gonna say but you do it's a very
unique thing that way you can't you that
you can never fail if you think of it
the right way so once you get to that
place where you can just kind of go
backwards and forwards anger them make
them happy get him in a friends he bore
them and you know how to control that
that gives you the ability to try a lot
of different different things what is